[Musica]
quella che vedete la nostra terra
probabilmente saprete già che il 70 per
cento della sua superficie è ricoperta
dall'acqua ma se guardate più
attentamente la superficie delle terre
emerse
essa vi apparirà verde verde perché
pensate che l'ottanta per cento di tutta
la biomassa del pianeta è rappresentato
da piante significa che l'ottanta per
cento e tutto quello che vive sulla
terra è rappresentato da organismi
vegetali
il restante verso il per cento se lo
spartiscono funghi e batteri agli
animali all'uomo non resta che lui o per
cento è indiscutibile poter affermare
che le piante sono le indiscusse
dominatrici di questo pianeta
e se sono apparse sulla terra 450
milioni di anni fa e da allora hanno
evoluto una serie di strategie
meccanismi adattativi che consentono
loro di colonizzare con successo
qualunque angolo del pianeta
ma cosa le rende così così interessanti
innanzitutto le piante sono organismi
autotrofi ossia traggono la loro fonte
di nutrimento dalle sostanze inorganiche
in sostanza acqua e anidride carbonica
vengono assemblate e tram usate il loro
fonte di nutrimento tramite l'energia
luminosa questo le rende la base della
nostra catena alimentare ma anche
l'unico strumento in nostro possesso per
sequestrare l'anidride carbonica e
quindi toglierla dall'atmosfera un conto
meno contrastare l'aumento responsabile
dei cambiamenti climatici
le piante inoltre non si muovono e se
germinano e vivono nello stesso punto
per tutta la loro vita hanno lasciato
agli animali la facoltà di spostarsi e
quindi di scappare di fronte a un
pericolo hanno invece investito in tutta
una serie di meccanismi che consentono
loro di monitorare l'ambiente
circostante e quindi anche prevenire
eventuali predazioni eventuali
cambiamenti che possono essere dannosi
alla loro sopravvivenza
questo che vedete è un ficus un enorme
albero tropicale che grazie a delle
radici aeree costituisce delle vere e
proprie colonne di sostegno che le
consentono così di svilupparsi con
queste imponenti strutture
ecco queste sono soltanto alcune delle
peculiarità che rendono le piante così
diverse dagli animali e di fatto
probabilmente è per questo che abbiamo
difficoltà a percepirle comprenderli e
soprattutto attribuire loro il valore
che invece queste meritano perché le
piante proprio così diverse da noi
rappresentano una vera propria fonte di
ispirazione che cosa si intende per bio
ispirazione la mia ispirazione è un
processo per cui si impara dalla natura
la si studia se ne capiscono i principi
di funzionamento e proviamo ad applicare
questi principi di funzionamento per
risolvere dei problemi quotidiani dei
problemi anche innovativi di tecnologia
leonardo fu il primo di cui abbiamo un
documentato approccio più ispirato egli
si rese conto che per la progettazione
la cancellazione di macchine volanti era
gli uccelli che si doveva guardare e
quindi studiarli e capirne i meccanismi
di volo perché per poi provare a da
strada dei principi di funzionamento da
punta appunto inserirli nei suoi disegni
oppure più recentemente l'ingegnere
francese gustave eiffel che si fece
carico della costruzione dell'imponente
torre si ispirò alla struttura con cui
le fibre di collagene sono disposte
all'interno delle nostre ossa in
particolare l'osso del femore imitandone
quindi la le norme robustezza
ma al contempo le norme leggerezza
garantendo quindi una struttura così
imponente ma estremamente leggera questo
ad esempio è una zampetta di jacko ejei
si riescono a avere un sistema adesivo
ad altissima prestazione grazie
all'interazione a livello atomico delle
particelle
e proprio i cechi hanno ispirato una
vasta gamma di sistemi adesivi appunto
ad altissima prestazione ma le piante
appunto le piante che cosa possono
insegnarci prima che ho detto che le
piante
non sono in grado di muoversi questo è
parzialmente vero infatti le piante
grazie ai semi riescono a sposarsi
tantissimo sia nello spazio che nel
tempo
i semi infatti sono quel meccanismo che
le pianto hanno evoluto per colonizzare
nuovi ambienti e diffondersi e la cosa
interessante è che per muoversi per
spostarsi non utilizzano l'energia
interna alla pianta quindi sottraendola
alla propria attività vitale ma anzi
sfruttano l'energia libera nell'ambiente
e quindi affidano all'architettura delle
forme dalla scelta di materiali
proprio questa loro capacità
questa che vedete è un'app ansia i semi
di bank sea riescono a viaggiare nel
tempo
la banca è una pianta australiana che si
è adattata a vivere in ambienti in cui
ci sono incendi boschivi molto frequenti
e i semi di mais e rimangono chiusi
all'interno di follicoli lignei
saldamente sigillati da delle resine le
quali resine si aprono solamente quando
raggiungono la temperatura critica e può
raggiungere i 500 gradi
il che significa che soltanto un
incendio potrà rilasciare nell'ambiente
i semi di questa pianta e questi semi
saranno pronti a riconquistare quell
ambiente devastato dall'incendio
oppure le noci di cocco le noci di cocco
sono delle abilissime viaggiatrici
sfruttano le correnti marine per solcare
i mari con le correnti appunto e
attendono che una mareggiata o un
uragano non riporti sulla spiaggia
pronte a determinare in un contesto
completamente diverso dalla pianta madre
oppure questo è un artiglio del diavolo
una pianta carnivora che grazie a questo
frutto disperde i propri semi
utilizzando il movimento degli animali
sono praticamente degli autostoppisti
questi questi frutti aspettano che un
animale li calpesti e si aggrappano
saldamente ai propri agli zoccoli e
viaggiano con loro nel per km
[Musica]
oppure possono sfruttare il vento
guardate ad esempio le diversità di
forme di questi semi auto rose anti i
profili alari di questi semi non hanno
niente da invidiare ai nostri aeroplani
ma anzi sfruttano le correnti
ascensionali e le turbolenze
dell'atmosfera pur senza alcuna
conoscenza aerodinamica oppure ci sono
delle piante che hanno evoluto dei
paracaduti di cui dotare i propri semi
questa è una pianta erbacea molto simile
al tarassaco che probabilmente conoscete
tutti alla particolarità di essere il
più grande paracadute è voluto sin
natura il diametro di questi porta
paracaduti può raggiungere anche i 10
centimetri e in questi paracaduti sono
costruiti utilizzando un unico materiale
che è la cellulosa e proprio perché in
natura niente deve andare sprecato
questi paracaduti sono dotati di un
sistema che consente loro di rimanere
saldamente chiusi quando il kill
ambiente troppo umido quando piove in
sostanza perché durante la pioggia non
avrebbero grosse chance di volare
lontano mentre sono perfettamente aperti
quando il clima è secco e quindi una
folata di vento può portarli via per km
e guardate più nel dettaglio la
tessitura di questi paracaduti queste
sono delle immagini fatte con il
microscopio elettronico e vedete come
queste queste fibre vanno a costituire
sia una struttura di porta una struttura
portante ma anche un ordita tessitura
che da questo paracadute una
permeabilità tale che gli consente di
avere un volo perfettamente stabile
questi ad esempio sono dei test fatti in
laboratorio che vi mostrano la stabilità
del volo dei questi paracaduti e da cui
potremo prendere un sacco di ispirazione
per sviluppare una nuova classe ad
esempio di materiali aerodinamici
appunto nuovi un nuovo concetto di
paracadute
un altro interessante esempio di
dispersione dei semi è dato dalle rose
questa piantina apparentemente
insignificante che però attirato la mia
attenzione quando
bravo all'agenzia spaziale europea con
il compito di provare a proporre dei
saluti delle soluzioni naturali che
potessero avere un'applicazione
all'esplorazione spaziale e questo se
meno si è rivelato un vero portento
infatti i semi di questo di questa
pianta sono dotati di una piccola codina
che vedete muoversi adesso la quale
risponde ai cambiamenti dell umidità
ambientale
in pratica è perfettamente dritta quando
l'ambiente è molto umido ed è
completamente attorcigliata quando è
secco
questi cambiamenti di umidità qui questa
codina riesce a cambiare la sua
configurazione sono sono molto piccoli e
quindi riesce ad avvantaggiarsi dei
cambiamenti di umidità che ci sono tra
il giorno e la notte
grazie a questo piccolo movimento di cui
appunto
naturalmente i semi sono dotati e che
non utilizza energia appunto interna al
seme questa questi semi ne riescono a
rosolare per terra a trovare una piccola
fessura dove dove potersi incuneare e lì
cominciano ad avvitarsi ed arrivano
praticamente a sotterrarsi completamente
ea quel punto possono iniziare la loro
determinazione abbiamo fatto delle prove
perché abbiamo provato a simulare come
potesse essere questa loro capacità di
auto sotterramento anche in suoli
extraterrestri quindi abbiamo provato la
granulometria della luna di marte e
questo ad esempio un asteroide in
pratica abbiamo visto che dopo tre
quattro cicli praticamente il 90 per
cento di questi semi mi riesce ad
entrare perfettamente sotto terra
[Musica]
abbiamo poi anche studiato il movimento
appunto di queste cose abbiamo misurato
la lunghezza e la disposizione delle
fibre che compongono tutta la struttura
e abbiamo provato a estrarne il
principio di funzionamento
questo che vedete ad esempio è un
modello meccanico che è stato costruito
successivamente a questi studi è che è
molto semplice è un elastico e un po di
silicone ma che è servito a validare le
osservazioni fatte in natura ea capire
appunto
se quelle osservazioni potevano avere
una applicazione semplice come questa
ecco queste come tante altre ricerche in
questo settore mettono nelle mani degli
ingegneri dei modelli di studio
interessantissimi che possono essere
presi ed è ingegnerizzati per la
risoluzione di una vastissima gamma di
problematiche e io sono convinta che la
natura da leonardo ad oggi ha sempre
rappresentato un enorme fonte di
ispirazione per l'uomo ma è proprio alle
piante che invece dovremmo focalizzarsi
perché sono quelle che essendo così
tante sul nostro pianeta e stando così
ancora poco conosciute possono
rappresentare un'ulteriore ventata di
innovazione alle idee di tutti i giorni
[Applauso]